how did you know John Hamm he was just
like a friend you know he's a guy that
we knew Sarah was friends with John and
then our mutual friend this guy told
John another John would bring him
sometimes to watch football on Sundays
and he's part of the my cousin Sal's
fantasy league in fact My Cousin Sal one
of his rules in his fantasy league and I
know you don't have much interest in
fantasy football but they have these
teams and Jon Hamm has a team
it's now has a rule that whoever wins uh
the championship that year gets to kick
one person out of the league
the next year so Jon Hamm is on the set
of Mad Men and these guys they all love
Mad Men they're like besides being
friendly with John they're enamored with
the idea that John is part of their
league and they have their Fantasy Draft
where they all sit around and pick the
players and John calls and he says
listen I'm still on set I'm going to be
two hours late uh you guys might want to
just go ahead without me they're like no
we're gonna wait for you and so he is
racing through the the shoot he races he
races to this bar he meets them there he
sits on the table he's got his magazines
he's in a bit of a sweat he sits down
they're like okay let's start the draft
and Sal says all right before we start
the draft I have to kick uh someone out
John you're kicked out of the
John gathers his stuff gets up and walks
right out the door oh my God that is so
great